hey welcome to a new project camp update
so we bought a piece of land and are
prototyping a more sustainable way of
living
let's see how that's gonna go and in the
last update you saw the containers we
built
arriving in portugal and in today's
update we're actually going to
clean the land so the containers can
come
so here we have the base camp installed
on this grass patch
and i want to clear up the bushes that
are around here
to put the containers so they can really
put them in front of the trees right
there
so basically clean up this area right
here but let me put on a time lapse and
get started
[Music]
i mean i have to admit after a while of
wrestling with these bushes
i really just started to develop some
hate towards these thorns
i mean at this point i got thorns in my
hands socks and even my butt
it got personal so sometimes when you're
taking this down
you see a few very thick strings that
are the root of
many others so if you kill them the
whole bush is gonna die
yeah feels so good to kill
nature and after continuing for a while
the thorns and bushes were flattened
down
but not really flat flat i needed
something really heavy to flatten it
so there was really only one thing i
could think of to do next
[Music]
and after everything was really flat it
was time to take it out
[Applause]
take out all the thorns i've never seen
so many thorns in my life
but also taking out the bushes and roots
that come with it
and it's kind of boring to do and the
only real motivation i had was
that while we're cleaning we're making
this big pile of thorns
and next we're gonna put those massive
piles on fire
watch them burn so once we took
everything out
yeah and this stuff burned surprisingly
well and fast
even when we just took it out and is
still fresh and wet
and this is actually one of the reasons
it's important to keep land like this
clean from these bushes
especially in the summer it can get
really dry and these easily catch fire
so generally everyone here is very happy
when you remove thorns
so this smoke is a little celebration
although i'm not sure if the neighbors
would agree with that
so now the whole area is clean but we
still need to make some floor spaces for
the container
and while working on this i broke the
tool
i broke the tool the wooden part broke
from the metal part
but we don't really have many tools
around to repair things with
but luckily simple tools require simple
fixes
so i could manage to fix this thing
using a rock as a hammer and continue to
work
so we cut it uh the spaces for the
container but they're not very flat
yet uh so i'm gonna level them uh to
make sure
all the soil is straight and the
container is water
water balanced how do you say that in
english
so
time to do some digging
so the leveling itself is pretty
straightforward just moving a lot of
soil from one place to another
as you can see here in this corner
there's quite a height difference
there's like
34 centimeters difference in
leveling height and after the rough
leveling work is done
i did it a bit more refined and now the
main leveling work is done
but the soil itself is still very loose
you kind of want to press it a bit but
just me and my boots didn't really do
the job
i needed something more heavy
so the area is now pretty leveled the
van is flat however
the van isn't really the exact same
thing as a container it's like three
thousand kilo versus
six thousand kilogram so it might still
move a bit
when we actually put it down onto the
soil
so i want to find some pieces of wood or
stone that while we put it here with the
crane
we can actually make sure to balance it
really precise and accurately
um so yeah we need to go to the
warehouse and the warehouse is basically
situated right in the middle of the land
and it's kind of like a shop or a
material bank
they just have so many valuable things
so yeah here let me show you you look at
this
warehouse it has wooden beams
it has roof tiles it has wooden beams
and roof tiles
in that corner they also have some
wooden beams and some roof tiles
you can really find anything basically
in this warehouse
and it's all free
so this shot actually burned down during
the fire and the roof collapsed
here you can still see traces of that
but
within this burnt wood you can still
find good wood as well
so the land is now ready the workspace
container can come
right here there where i am waving
and the kitchen container is coming
right there where the van is now parked
so now we just have to wait all right so
that was it
the land is now all cleared uh ready for
the containers to arrive
but as you might have seen in the
previous update we just have to wait for
the municipality to clean the road
that the containers can actually come if
you want to see that update and all the
other updates have a look here
if you want to see how it's going to go
next make sure to subscribe
so we release a new update video when
it's time
and if you want to make sure we can pay
the guy with a crane to come here to
drop off the container
make sure to visit
support.projectcamp.com to see how you
can help out
thanks for watching see you in the next
update